So this next story started to develop last
night.
And I have to tell you, I can't wait.
I am really like a kid on Christmas morning
and I'm Jewish.
But the metaphor just works like a kid on
Christmas morning waiting for video to be
released because Donald Trump yesterday was
interviewed for an upcoming episode of 60
Minutes.
And we've learned that in the middle of the
interview, Trump abruptly and furiously got
up and left, ending the interview with 60
Minutes correspondent Lesley Stahl and then
started tweeting ridiculous things about the
interview.
This has to be seen to be believed.
The reporting is that in the interview, Trump
became frustrated with the questions that
Leslie Stall was asking.
That tracks perfectly with Trump's displeasure
at being asked real questions and in particular,
in situations where he can't weasel his way
out.
The example from last week's town hall where
Savannah Guthrie actually pressed Trump about
his obvious lies as to when was he tested?
Was he tested for Corona virus before the
debate?
And Trump was obviously lying and being dishonest.
And Trump lost it on Savannah Guthrie, saying
she was terrible, horrible, all this stuff.
Same thing happened with 60 Minutes after
about 45 minutes of the 60 Minutes interview.
Trump gets up and leaves and just doesn't
come back.
But he was highly, highly triggered first.
Trump tweeted a video of the interviewer,
Leslie Stall, not wearing a mask at the White
House as an attack on her.
We later learned that this was just moments
after Trump abruptly left the interview.
And Leslie Stall, of course, being on camera,
had removed her mask.
And she was talking to producers about like
it's Trump coming backers.
Is this over?
She hadn't yet put her mask on.
Trump attacking her for that.
That's already weird.
But then Trump bizarrely tweeting about the
interview itself, that, quote, I am pleased
to inform you that for the sake of accuracy
in reporting, I am considering posting my
interview with Leslie Stahl of 60 Minutes
prior to airtime.
This will be done so that everybody can get
a glimpse of what a fake and biased interview
is all about.
Everyone should compare this terrible electoral
intrusion with the recent interviews of sleepy
Joe Biden.
So I guess the implication is maybe Trump
has the raw video of the entire interview.
Or maybe Trump's just lying.
Who the hell knows?
But apparently a reporter asking real questions
is considered an intrusion on the electoral
process.
Now, per Donald Trump, this is a joke, guys.
We are a joke.
The country is a joke.
This man is a joke.
It really can't continue.
And in normal situations, a president being
unable to handle a 60 Minutes interview, walking
out.
It would be a national scandal if Barack Obama
had done this.
It would be 24/7 on right wing news saying
the president can't handle it.
What an embarrassment.
He can't stand the heat.
If he can't stand up to Leslie Stall, how
can he stand up to Xi and Putin and Kim Jong?
Right.
All that stuff, if it had been Obama with
Trump.
Trump has so weaponized his followers against
the media in a dystopian act of hostility
that the Trump ists are furious.
If you look at the places online where the
trump is hang out, the Trump ists are furious
with Leslie Stall and with 60 Minutes.
But what we can be sure of is that if Trump
walked out, the interview must have been really
bad, because even interviews that you and
I recognize as having gone badly for Donald
Trump.
Trump thinks he did well.
So if even Trump thinks he didn't do well
in the interview, it must be a complete disaster
if Trump flees the interview and starts slamming
the interviewer on Twitter.
You know, it went really, really bad.
And I hope that this is released Sunday.
Very much looking forward to it.